i be seated members of the jury
the objection by
mr shellhorn was sustained in the last
testimony by
the doctor will be stricken from the
record and you're not to consider it
and the specific testimony is
where the doctor said his his previous
testimony where he talked about
mr barrissone's biggest fear
which was completely delusional in his
opinion was that the children would be
taken and killed by lauren canorack
and robert goodwin
that much you can consider but his
follow-up line that it was linked to a
specific post there's no evidence in the
record of that
that the defender never reviewed any
such post according to the doctor's
testimony so that last part must be
stricken you are not to consider it in
your deliberations
right
let's bring the doctor
[Music]
now go ahead mr blancas continue thank
you
doctor based on your clinical interviews
the psychological testing
and the information that you reviewed in
the record
did you form an opinion
with regards to michael barrisson's
state of mind at the time of the
incident yes i did
and is that opinion as to a degree of
psychological medical certainty yes it
is what is your opinion with regards to
michael barrasson's state of mind
at the time of this incident
at the time of the shooting
he suffered from a mental disorder
a psychotic break a delusional disorder
which degraded his thinking to such an
extent that he did not know what he was
doing was wrong
did he understand the nature and quality
of his actions no
nothing further
all right cross-examination
thank you judge
doctor good afternoon good afternoon
you're not board certified are you
they don't have board certification and
for psychologists it's for psychiatrists
have you ever had any problems with your
license no
now your cv indicates that you had
weekly meetings with uh dr james wallach
yeah in 2010. yes
he's a lawyer and a clinical
psychologist yes
what was the nature of your meetings
with him i would go over cases and i
wanted him to
serve as an attorney to question me
hard
in terms of what we were talking about
so i get more practice
why did you start meeting with him on a
weekly basis in 2000 i wanted to improve
i've done that over the years with
different people
i uh
contacted an expert in
on the mmpi dr caldwell
and i met with him weekly and other
individuals that did the same so what i
tried to do in terms of my career i try
to find someone who is more
knowledgeable better than me and so to
speak i like to play tennis with them to
help my game
now your cv indicates uh that you were
a postdoctoral fellow in neuropsychology
at columbia university yes
and that's normally a two-year full-time
program it is
and you did the fellowship or you're a
fellow for nine months i i yes i left
the program
had you ever published any peer-reviewed
science published in any peer-reviewed
scientific journals
uh i don't know if it's peer-reviewed
but i wrote an article with arnold
lazarus on multimodal therapy
that was the article from 1990 yes
what's multimodal therapy it's a form of
cognitive behavior therapy
it was developed by arnold lazarus he
was a eminent uh psychologist at rutgers
university
and it basically
it
tries to have interventions
with multiple components to it not just
one component
but it looks at the broad
kind of player possibilities of
interventions for a person
and that's based or excuse me that's
related to
therapy it's not related to
diagnostic uh
no it's therapy
now you were the chief operating officer
for the publishing company that puts put
that
book out one book there was a book that
was written by dr fay
prescription for quality relationship
and i developed a friendship with him
and through him i met
dr lazarus
now you're a member of the american
psychological association yes are you a
fellow
no
do you know what the criteria is to be
elected a fellow i don't know
would you be surprised if i told you it
was based on contributions
he's a member of the association judge
he said he didn't he said he did he
didn't said he didn't know
move on have you ever held any offices
with any professional associations no
have you ever received any awards from
any professional associations
no i just received the reward from the
prosecutor's office in hudson county on
a particular case that i did
so with respect to your peers uh in
these professional organizations you've
never received any awards no
now you indicated that you've testified
at trial in the past yes
have you testified for both the
prosecution and the defense yes can you
estimate approximately how many times in
the last
10 years you've done that i don't know
offhand um
but over the um
since my career at least 100 times
for each side
no not no enough for each side let's say
50 50.
have you ever been hired by the
prosecutor or the defense and then given
an opinion
that's inconsistent with the party
that's hiring you oh yeah
can you estimate approximately how many
times you've done that in the last time
can you do that but
i did that with dyfus
and i did that with a parental
representation unit
now i saw on your cv that you listed an
update you attended at harvard medical
school in october of 2018 yes
how many days was that
it must have been four days
why do you say must have been it usually
runs from like wednesday to sunday
so it would be all day wednesday
thursday friday saturday and half a day
on sunday
you know how many hours that would be
when you say days
jay uh
i don't know eight hours a day i'm not
sure
how would that particular uh update be
different from the continuing education
seminars that are listed on page three
well the ones that are listed on page
three for continuing education or just
within forensic psychology
the the other ones that i listed
um
was on basically uh dementia
neuropsychology and psychiatric issues
so that's how i differentiated it
have you ever given any seminars or
presentations to your peers in the field
of psychology well i i gave two
presentations to
the fellows at
columbia on forensic psychology
so i testified in the case and the
psychiatrist who was dr simmering he was
the director
we were on opposite sides in that
particular case and after i wrote my
report he contacted me and asked me if i
would present to the fellows so i
presented for two years
that was in 2008 and 2009
you've never presented that into the
national seminars or anything like that
no i had no interest
now you indicated that you gave a
battery of psychological tests to
michael barrisson yes you would agree
with me that you would never make a
diagnosis based on a psychological test
correct
now you rendered a number of
psychological diagnoses for mr bearson
yes
would you agree with me that only
delusional disorder would affect his
ability to know and appreciate the
nature and quality of his actions yes
however
for the intentional problem that
contributes to why he has the delusional
disorder magnifies it
but on its own it wouldn't affect his
abilities he participates in the forming
of
importing causing the impact
of the
delusions
[Music]
doctor would you agree with me that two
people can have the same experience but
perceive it differently totally
and would you agree with me that someone
being mistaken about something is not a
delusion
no
it's not
it's not a delusion a delusion is an
experience that a person has
that is um
put together in their mind incorrectly
and i gave the example of like a
delusion like for example michael
barason saw
a facebook post
and on the facebook post
there was an orange color
the orange color generated in his mind
the idea of flames fire from that he
generated in his mind the notion
that uh his place was going to be burnt
down
okay
so
i could look at it and someone else
could look at it and look at it
differently but the way he's thinking
about it is disturbed
well that wasn't my question my question
was if someone has a mistake about a
fact or they're mistaken about a fact
does that mean delusional no if i
if i said to you
that columbus
came to
the new world in 1592 you i would be
wrong
you know and that's not a delusion
that's just a statement of fact
would you agree with me that
a feeling is not the same as a delusion
correct a delusion is a thought
it generates feelings
now i'm going to ask you some questions
about what you reviewed and what you
didn't review in the case but would you
agree with me in general that if there
was something that you didn't know or
something that you didn't account for
that you found out was different later
on that could change your opinion it
would influence it it depends on what it
is
i think you indicated that you had
reviewed a great deal of the discovery
in the case
did you review any of the witnesses
recorded statements yes i do
and you indicated that you reviewed
the defendant's written statement that
he prepared for dr simran yes
and you said where you you said in your
report that that was only 51 pages that
it should be 91 pages yeah it's 91 pages
when i saw however i thought within that
there were duplicate pages
i can show you
all of those pages if you'd like to go
through them uh
to check whether there are duplicates or
are not duplicates
um i can't i would not want to do that
now but i would love to meet with you
because i clearly remember reading it
and i was remarked this is
so very repetitious
did you corroborate anything that you
read there with any of the other
discovery
um
would you have to be more specific on
that i'm sorry
if you saw something or read something
there that was
and look i have to say this
i don't trust anything that a person
says to me
so i
you know they could claim one thing or
another and i tried to see if there's
um an agreement so he would tell me all
kinds of things negative about let's say
lauren canorack and when i looked it up
it uh
that was coherent
with what he said the event took place
and you mentioned earlier that you spoke
with dr pacone
but then you indicated you corrected
yourself that was a typo in your report
yes
are you uh aware that she's not a doctor
i thought she was a doctor a
psychologist
and your notes actually indicate your
handwritten notes indicate phd next to
her name yes i mean where did you get
that from i thought that's what she said
phd
so you believe when you spoke to ms
picone
i thought she was a psychologist that
she told you she had a phd maybe she
didn't tell me but i thought she was a
psychologist i thought she was a doctor
now mr uh belingus asked you some
questions on direct examination about
the discrepancies between
your notes and your report and when you
actually met with michael barrett's own
versus william yes and i wrote down on
direct examination that you said
i'm gonna check and see if my notes are
correct all right well he's refreshing
his recollection i suppose
but you don't have to you don't have to
reference what you wrote down well
doctor just asked a question
did you meet with
michael barrissone on october 29th
november 5th november 6th november 19th
november 20th
december 4th and december 5th
no i said i thought i said december 11th
well that's why i'm asking the question
fourth and the 11th
and you acknowledge that that's wrong in
your report
no i acknowledge the fact that the dates
i just gave you just read to me that's
the correct time
that was the correct dates that i saw
him
but that's not what it indicates
as far as the contacts and the the bill
that you gave correct correct
now i'm going to ask you some questions
about the various tests that you
administered doctor you talked about the
rorschach test yes
and you didn't actually administer the
rorschach
doctor you were asked questions on
direct about the rorschach test
yes
you scored
michael barissone on the rorschach
using the
using nextner correct yes that's the
exeter system yes
just lost my nose sure
now there are a number of different
scoring systems for the workshop test
correct yes
and
you used the exner sort scoring system
when you did the score yes
are you aware of the rorschach research
council
um
yes
you're aware that that was a council
that was formed by john extra himself
in the mid 1990s okay yes
and are you aware that that council
identified a number of significant
problems with the egzner scoring system
yes
for example they noted that there's
issues with reliability between
different scorers
that's with all the rorschach systems
they indicated that the egzner system
was of questionable questionable
validity
questionable norms
they also indicated that there was no
research data that supported the x-men
scoring system i doubt that
let me show you if i can
s-409
for identification
uh in a breakout room please judge if i
could sure
it'll appear on that computer screen so
once it's pulled up
foreign
doctor can you see that screen okay
that's an article from psychological
science correct
okay
and does that indicate or refresh your
memory on the first page in that
italic type on the left hand side
the article was written by james wood
and i like his work i have his book on
the rorschach
uh he's very critical of the use of the
rorschach completely
now the rorschach is very controversial
test there's two systems that exist
right now one by um exner eczema system
and one by meyer
there'd be very few people that would
agree with you to throw the baby out
with the bath and while i uh i tend to
support james woods analysis of the
rorschach i think you're going overboard
by saying that the system is recording
in progress
i think you're going overboard by trying
to imply
that the system is um
uh
negated by people in the psychological
community in a psychological community
um
so you don't agree that the exeter
system has a tendency to find illness
that isn't present
that that's that's a common knowledge on
the rorschach system it's a common
knowledge right but that's not the full
story
it's just not and doctor i'm just asking
you if you could answer my questions so
do you or do you not agree
that the exner system has a tendency to
find an illness that isn't present
that's one one point of view on that
that's one point of view
that's not the full
kind of play
of um views on that
did you just uh who was the
individual that you just referenced
doctor james wood
i'm going to show you uh what's been
marked as s410
[Music]
doctor is that an article from the
journal of personality assessment yes
and that was uh among the other authors
listed there are gregory meyer yeah i
know him
i know
cited gregory meyer in your report
yes
he has a another system that's been
developed and he's actually a member of
the rorschach research council yes
if
may i say something to you and he
actually
developed this additional
or different test the rpac yeah
it's a a rorschach system that's
different
a lot of these things you're touching on
are very controversial
so if you get the book on the rorschach
system by
wood at all you'll see that
they imply
i'm not saying this is the case but they
imply that meyer was bought out
basically
by exner he had
written initially like in a dissertation
a criticism of the action system
excellent then placed him on board with
regards to
the
[Music]
his group he was working with and he
changed his opinion that's that's the
implication in that book on the
rorschach
it's with gary lillian fell l-i-l-l-i
e-f-e-l-d
gary lillian fell wood and others
so
you're heading in into a very
controversial area
extern the exorcism is controversial
all the systems are controversial
i think i even referenced that within my
report
you know saying that
there's questionable validity on some of
these systems i still think you could
use it so i also referenced a book
which is a legitimate book on assessment
of psychosis
did you testify today about the
potential issues or the validity issues
not at all not at all because
that's not the summon substance of my
report
what i was doing is
i was taking the information from the
action that came out
or the the rorschach that was scored and
it fits in with other information
it
it's supported by other information
now do you have to pay any fees to use
that exner yes computer program
all the tests that i did i had to pay
for
so they're approximately forty dollars a
test maybe a little bit more do you have
to update that program periodically at
all
uh it depends on which company you're
using but like basically um
you pay per test
and you have to like for the uh
test from the psych corporation
you buy a um
access for a hundred dollar you buy an
access for doing the test and then you
pay per test
so it's enough for free
who runs uh the egg snare system now or
the comprehensive system now that uh
john exeter he passed away i don't know
who's in charge of it what happened was
the family initially said that they
didn't want any additional research but
they change their opinion on that
are you aware that it's run by his
daughter
it could be
did you know that she's not a
psychologist or a psychiatrist to me
i'm be honest i think you're heading
down a bad road because it's not a
doctor okay doctor we're not here to
argue i apologize
mr doctor
both of you be quiet
your role here
is not to opine on any road the
prosecutor may be going down
that's his decision
your job is to answer the questions
that's it to the best of your ability
now we got that out of the way ask
another question mr sheldon
doctor i'm going to ask you about these
scores that you uh produced for the
rorschach test in this case
do you remember the interpretive report
that you got after rescoring the uh the
rorschach
i don't have it in front of me but
i remember like key elements of it
specifically
did you list what you considered to be
the salient findings in your report yes
what's silly it mean
key findings
on page seven well i'll show it to you
doctor uh s 435
for identification
do you have that doctor yes and you
would agree with me that that's the
interpretive report for the scores you
gave michael barisson on the rorschach
i guess yes yes
if i direct your attention down to page
seven
specifically under number two
which is about halfway down the page
would you agree with me
that
it indicates there
that the individual
has a potential for impulsiveness
yes
you didn't include that in your report
did you
i don't know what i wrote on that i
thought that i wrote that he was
emotionally unstable
um
and i can direct your attention doctor i
see you looking at your report to pages
eight and nine
okay so you'd agree with me that the
rorschach scoring that that you did
indicated uh
and reflected a potential for
impulsiveness but you didn't include
that in your report yes
moving down on s score 35 which is the
rorschach on page eight
and i'm going to direct your attention
to number seven
does it indicate there
this individual exerts less considerably
less control over feelings than most
adults yes
does it indicate does not necessarily
signify that he is unable to exert
self-control and keep his emotions in
check but that he chooses not to do so
okay
you agree with me that's from the
results that you got from the this is
from that computer printout
and you didn't include that in your
report no
drawing your attention down to page 12
doctor
specifically number 21.
does it indicate
the individual is
excessively committed to seeing the
world accurately
yes and realistically
okay
and you would agree with me you didn't
put that in your report
no i don't need to on that
because for the simple reason that if an
individual has a delusional disorder i
did indicate
from another reference that it's not
going to be picked up
by
this test
i had a long quote
so here's the thing
if you want to pick pieces out of this
report and say it doesn't fit in
with
everything i've written
the point is is that i'm looking for
things that overlap that agree with each
other
so
that's a factor that i use in terms of
generating a report
but there's no way that you could write
a report and think that you could put
every single piece together you have to
use some kind of clinical judgment
well you'd agree with me that if there
was
a common thread here of any of the
things we've talked about with these
other reports
and other tests rather and you didn't
put it in your report
but that
means that you ignored it i didn't
ignore it i didn't ignore it
i also just said to you previously
that i gave a quote from a current book
on the assessment of psychosis and it
said that you're not going to be able to
pick up
delusional disorder on the russia
and if you're trying to imply that just
because he has a clear view of reality
that doesn't necessarily follow
you also didn't put any of these quotes
in your report or these passages in your
report and then distinguish them or
differentiate them did you
i didn't i don't believe i quoted i
thought i summarized
what i saw was in the reports
we just pointed out a number of things
that you didn't put in your report
correct you'll find that with every all
the testing that's done
and lastly on page 12 of 13 number 24.
you indicated earlier
in your testimony on direct examination
that the defendant was incapable of
understanding the nature and quality of
his actions yes
does page 12 indicate the individual is
capable of maintaining a connected flow
of associations in which ideas follow
each other in a comprehensible manner
okay but you also recall from yeah it
says that but you also recall from a
report that said it was a very low
number of responses
that uh were produced
i also wrote in my report
the least number of responses you have
to have 14 responses if you have less
than 14 responses you don't have a valid
profile
and the fewer the responses are and it's
discussed by wood
and his associates
you can push down the pathology i
mentioned that in my report
so
you need to take that into account
that you could have a suppressed
level of pathology in it given the fact
that the number of responses were very
low
and i think my question was just that
that was a
indication that you received from the
tests and from the scores but that you
didn't include that in your report but i
just said that you could read this
but if you also know how many responses
are given in the score and i have a
section here
that you could have a spuriously low
sign of pathology in the report given
you have very few responses
all right doctor let's move on to the
mmpi
the mmpi2
did you rescore this test
i ran it through the computer
now i think you testified on direct
examination
about the mmpi two correct
yes
and you testified in particular with
respect to scale six can you remember or
can you remind the jury what skill six
scale six measures paranoia
and it's fair to say that none of these
scale titles the names shouldn't be
interpreted literally
no you should look further into the test
you should look at the subcomponent
scores
pa1 pa2 pa3
pa1
shows delusional thought content
of a very serious nature and doctor i'm
just asking you about scale 6 yes so
scale 6 is titled paranoia yes but it
doesn't literally mean that it's testing
parallel
well it's just said literally that you
have to look at other scales on there
if you literally look at
other
experts in the field
they're going to say it measures
delusional disorder
a score of 90.
so the high score of 90 on scale six
you would say is indicative of someone
with delusional disorder
yes
and not just simply on that
and also and doctor
please don't get ahead of me i
appreciate it thank you
well isn't it true that people with high
scores on scale six
rarely
endorse the existence of delusions
i don't believe that at all i've never
seen that
who is uh james butcher oh i know james
butcher he's one of the mmpi uh
figures
and i think you cited him in your report
as well correct i might have
he's a reputable
person in with respect to the mpi too
uh have you ever looked at his book
using the mnpi 2 in forensic assessment
no
judge if i may approach
i don't have this marked as an exhibit
all right well what's the next exhibit
number just so we have a reference
i believe it's s
454
that's 454.
do you have an objection mr malinkas
come to cyborg
attention here to uh page 54.
you would agree with me that this block
in the middle talks about scale six
paranoia let me read it
here's a problem you have with us
every t-score is here and doctor
you'll have a chance okay
but you'd agree with me
that this does say
with respect to scale six paranoia
the existence of delusions and paranoid
thought process
are rarely identified within this within
this score
i agree that it says that there but i
also agree the fact that it doesn't have
the score of 90 in there
and that's a very different um course of
another color
you indicated you're you're familiar
with james butcher yes
now people who score
high on scale six are also generally
described as being suspicious
overly sensitive argumentative
prone to blame others yes
people with high scores on scale six
also often express their hostility
overtly and rationalize it as a result
of what others have done it's pot yes
yes
and you indicated this defendant michael
barrison scored
high on skill six
i indicated that a t score of 90
i've never seen
in my career an individual score that
high
on scale six
with
really scales that within normal limits
and the reference you're giving doesn't
give very high score it doesn't give any
scores it just gives a general
discussion
but you agree with me that james butcher
and others wrote in that report
that an individual
who scores high on the scale for
paranoia
rarely endorses the existence of
delusions
it's incredibly misleading you would
agree with me that on the references
i'll ask the questions respectfully
just answer the questions please so you
agree that you just read that in that
book yes i read that
now you indicated that some of the tests
that you administered the defendant
showed difficulty with his concentration
on some of the tests yes
on the mmpi2
which is s434
for identification and we're going to
pull that up for you now doctor
did michael barissone endorse the number
of persecutory ideas
yes
and you'd expect that of a criminal
defendant who's on trial
not necessarily i would expect that
someone who has a delusional disorder to
get a score of 90
on skill six and a score of 105 on scale
pa1
and also to get a score of 88
on the
caldwell index well if he indicates in
in respect to question 99 someone has it
in for me and says it's true yes
you would expect that for someone who's
been charged with a crime
i i no i i just think you're
i i just don't agree with you
now with respect to the mcmi four
yes i don't know if you uh specifically
mentioned that on direct examination
well i administered it
however
i tried to check out the cut scores by
looking up rogers and i didn't use it
even though the test came out
in the same direction as the other tests
because the um validity scales were weak
on that
why did you use the mcmi4
it's a legitimate test i wanted to look
at personality disorder in him
however
i want to look at the current cut scores
so i looked up rogers and
he didn't have any information on that
and then i decided not to use it given
the fact that i wasn't sure if it was
valid the conclusions
doctor you mentioned the pai test on
your direct examination do you recall
that yes
and specifically with the pai
i think you testified
that you did validity testing with
respect to that test
there's validity testing on there
judge this has been marked as s436 fine
doctor directing your attention to page
two
at the very top of the
every page on this document does it
indicate warning validity scales
indicate hypotheses may not be valid
certainly does
and this test itself actually indicated
that there was
the possibility of deliberate distortion
i also indicated in my report
that i used richard rogers cut scores
for nim and mal
they're different from the scores on
this test
the cut scores for rogers the nim
negative
impression management has to be above
110 and the mal which is like an index
score of a group of different scores has
to be above five the mal that was
calculated was three
and the uh nim that was calculated was
92.
so uh as i just said i went with rogers
with regards to this and i looked for
rogers with regard to the mcmi and i
didn't see anything so i didn't score
the mcmi
but that's why there's a discrepancy
so with respect to the pai
it does indicate that there's some
the possibility of some deliberate
distortion
with respect
to
the
one of the key experts in the united
states
i don't know anyone who's uh more
renowned than richard rogers he's
written multiple uh
articles and books
on malingering and deception
the scores that are being shown here are
not invalid
did you indicate that in your report yes
you indicated that the pai
you wrote in your report at the pai
indicated quote the possibility of
millennials you wrote that in your
report i indicated in my report that i
used the cut scores from richard rogers
for nim and mal i indicated that
i didn't use the scores that were shown
here
well specifically i'll direct your
attention to page 10 of the pai that you
administered and you scored
does it indicate in the first full
paragraph
on page 10
the critical items should be reviewed to
evaluate the possibility of malingering
where is this now
on my report
pai page 10.
it's been marked for identification as s
436 and it should be on the screen in
front of you okay
yes
what is your question you see you see
there where this report
based on the test that you administered
and you scored
indicates the critical items should be
reviewed
to evaluate the possibility of
malingering i also just indicated you a
few times see that yes
i see that
and in that same paragraph does it say
regardless of the cause
in all capital letters
the test results potentially involve
considerable distortion
and are unlikely to be an accurate
reflection of the respondent's objective
clinical status
the following interpretation is provided
only as an indication
of the respondent's self description
you agree with me that the pai that you
administered and scored gave you that
indication
i agree with
what you just read there but i also
agree with myself
that richard rogers who's a higher
authority
than the
computer printout
would argue that those scores were not
mo they were genuine they were not uh an
indication of feigning
and i gave you the score is that in your
report it's in my report it says that
here is that the critical items should
be reviewed for the possibility of
malingering now what it says in my
report is that i use richard rogers
cut scores for it
well here's what rogers did
doctor okay please just answer my
questions
i will thank you
now the pai also gave a number of
possibilities didn't it yes
did it indicate the diagnostic
possibility of delusional disorder
no
did it indicate that malingering should
be ruled out it could be given the fact
that using the incorrect cut scores on
here
well let me draw your attention and this
is a score this is a test you chose
correct
you chose to administer the pai to the
defendant let me let me make a comment
to you doctor could you please just
chill for my i use this test right but i
have to use my judgment too i have more
knowledge
that i tried to use in terms of
understanding it
so i looked at
the cut scores by richard rogers he
takes into
richard rogers is trying to
reduce
false positives
so he and his group took this test they
wanted to
reduce false positives false positive
would be say someone is malingering when
they're not and actually malingering is
not a diagnosis as you probably know
you chose to administer the pai to
michael barisson correct yes
you took the results and you put them
into this particular program to score it
correct yes
the program
gave you a number of various
information
clinical features
treatment considerations
possible diagnosis correct yes
and you didn't include
all of those things in your report i
would never encourage everything in the
report i would use my judgment on the
report the test gave two things
the equality scales
and also gave clinical scales the
validity scale said
that the test was accurate
and where the results of the pai that
you have in front of you as s46
didn't match your ultimate diagnosis
you didn't put anything your in your
report about why you ignored that
or why you distinguished it
i indicated that i'm not putting down my
lingering given the fact that there's no
evidence of feigning on this test
because i used more accurate cut scores
so where it says
there's the possibility of malingering
you're saying that feigning is not
indicated at all by this test
correct
doctor you also mentioned
that you administered the 16
pf test yes
i know you mentioned several of the
factors
i don't think you mentioned factor l
what does factor l measure vigilance
high suspiciousness
did michael verizon have an extremely
high score on this scale yes his scale
or his score rather for this scale was
at the top of the range yes
and a score
like that
would suggest problems with the
projection of anger
correct
it would suggest a preoccupation with
power dynamics
correct
you'd agree with me that's not indicated
in your report
well i interpret it differently than you
i didn't interpret it as power dynamics
i interpreted it as hyper suspiciousness
doctor i'm going to show you what's been
marked as s443
for identification
this is the 16 pf
results
from the test that you administered
and you just indicated that you wouldn't
say that factor l
deals with the preoccupation of power
dynamics but you'd agree with me that
that's exactly what it says in the test
results it says it there
now you mentioned doctor that you gave
the sirs to correct yes
why did you pick the surge ii as opposed
to the surge 1.
well the source 2
is a better test
in that it was developed to reduce
[Music]
false positives
so in other words accusing someone of
either malingering or feigning when
they're not
it was an upgrade
well isn't it true that in the
scientific community that there are
concerns about whether the sur's to
accurately assess his feelings i'm going
to respond to you
that's a complete misstatement
now there were three
studies that came out
they criticized
the use of surge2
basically the problem
with those three studies
the design was poor
and what they used was
a test called the miller
forensic test
the miller forensic test is high on
sensitivity remember i gave the example
going through a magnetometer it goes off
the
sirs 2
is high on specificity
they use the wrong tests and the wrong
design
to criticize the
sirs too there was three of those
studies that was answered by rogers when
he went over the
designs of those studies
so if authors published an article
in a peer-reviewed
scientific journal
where they indicated that they had
concerns about whether the sur's to
accurately measures whether someone's
feigning or not you would disagree with
those authors and disagree with that
scientific study i would agree with
rogers when he analyzed those studies
and found that they were flawed those
studies were seriously flawed
what they did was they used a screening
test
for uh malingering or feigning a
screening test and they compared it to
his test his test is not a screening
test his test is designed to
have heightened
specificity
not have false positives
the other test on the other side the
miller was set up for high sensitivity
to go off every time a person walk
through that magnetometer this test only
goes off if someone walks through the
magnetometer like with a gun in their
pocket
doctor let me ask you some questions
about the tom
is that an acronym for the test of
memory malingering yes and you indicated
that you gave that test to michael
barrasson yes one of four tests
and you indicated that when you gave
michael barissone the test of memory
malingering that he had a four score
he had a score of 41
on trial 2 and trial four
and i think you indicated
that to the jury on direct examination
that
that score is poor it's on yes a score
um
under 45 is considered
a problem
with the exception if someone has some
kind of like brain injury
a tbi or something of that sort and you
didn't note any issues like that with mr
barrisson well i did write
after i considered that
that he has some problem with
visual memory and there's some problem
with the tension and he also mentioned
that an odd finding was that on the vip
which is a a very certain that's the
a very superior test
on the
non-verbal part there was an indication
a problem sustaining attention so i
hypothesized that there's a possibility
that the 41 score was due to the fact of
his uh difficulty in different areas
now you just testified that a score
under 45
is a problem
yes i think that was your exact words
and you indicated that michael barrasson
scored a 41 on the test of memory
malignant correct yes
that was on
two of the trials correct
trial two and the recognition trial
his score on trial one was a 35 yes
you didn't include that in your report
you don't that's not you not how you
analyze it
i didn't ask that question doctor you
would never include that
well a score of 41
is actually indicative of someone who is
likely malingering correct
possibly so if they don't have any other
difficulty that's maybe impacting the
score
judge i'm going to ask
to show
the witness i have it on my computer but
because it was highlighted i think it's
difficult to read
so this has been marked as s422
and doctor i apologize that this is uh
difficult to read here
but would you agree with me that it says
any score lower than 45 on trial two
or on the retention trial
should raise concerns that the
individual is not putting forth maximum
effort and is likely malingering keep on
reading
rather
i can't read that
i'm just i'm sorry
rather than using the score of 45 as a
rigid cut
cut off it should be viewed as a
guideline yes with the likelihood of
malingering increasing as the score
deviates further from the normative
baseline
for each specific diagnostic group okay
you didn't indicate that in your report
did you
no what i indicated was he's got a score
of 41 and 41 and i indicated possible
reasons for the low score and it's
inconsistent with the
high scores on
the
vip
and you excluded the 35.
i would never report 30 the first call
it's not part of the analysis
you give the first test and you give the
second and you give the retention
judge i don't anticipate that i'm going
to finish in the next 15 or 20 minutes i
can certainly keep going
um i want to keep going a little while
longer since we don't have um tomorrow
morning
so you can keep going just just for 10
minutes
you had been asked questions about
amnesia on direct examination yes
and you indicated that uh you diagnosed
the defendant with dissociative amnesia
yes localized
and i think you testified on direct
examination that it could be
dissociative amnesia yes
i chose to diagnose that when you were
asked whether you were sure of that or
certain made that uh opinion within a
reasonable degree of psychological
certainty is that the same as it could
have been
yes
more likely than not
now you agree with me that there's no
memory disorder that's selective just
for criminal behavior
i don't know what that means
was there anything
in the dsm
that would indicate someone could have a
memory disorder that's selective just
for the time that they're doing
something that's criminal it's possible
i wouldn't rule out any of that and i
wouldn't use the word malingering
because if you're going to use the word
lingering you have to show a test
that is positive for feigning
there's no tests that i gave that show
any feigning so my question was
is there any diagnosis
in the dsm
that deals with someone's memory
being selective just for the time when
they commit a crime no
now you'd agree with me that the dsm
also indicates
that veined amnesia is found more
commonly in individuals with legal
problems
well i think the reference is not they
they say
um
they don't use feign they use malignant
amnesia
right
as a v code the v code in that book
uh i think on page 715 or so it
basically states that in criminal
situations you should suspect
that there's malingering but it doesn't
prove that there's malingering in this
case because it's not just a simple
criminal act it's the fact that
he can't remember something that was
incredibly stressful
and my question was isn't it true that
feigned amnesia is more commonly found
in individuals with legal problems
i don't know that
i don't know any data on that is it true
that feigned amnesia is more commonly
found in individuals who wish to escape
stressful situations
um
dissociative amnesia often comes with
people who are in stressful situations
but they don't call it
using a term that doesn't exist you're
saying feigned amnesia
the term that's in there is dissociative
amnesia that's an emotional type of
amnesia
judge i'm going to refer to the dsm-5
again this hasn't been marked
all right
and i'll mark it when we're done with
torch
doctor you just said that feigned
amnesia isn't a term that's in the dsm
not that i know of with the diagnostic
number i'm going to direct your
attention to page
298 you would agree with me
okay that this page talks about
dissociative amnesia yes that's the
diagnosis that you came up with for
michael bearson
correct
you would agree with me that there are a
number of things listed after the
criteria diagnostic features correct
associated features risk and prognostic
factors yes
and if we get here to page 301
it says factitious disorder and
malindering correct correct and you'd
agree with me that the book
says feigned amnesia is more common in
individuals with
legal problems correct yes it also says
feigned amnesia is more common in
individuals with a wish to escape
stressful circumstances okay
does it then go on many individuals who
malinger confess spontaneously or when
confronted
well
it's a strange article there
because there's no specific diagnosis
for famed amnesia it doesn't have a
number
there's no number doctor if you recall
my question it wasn't whether or not
there was a number or whether or not
there was a specific diagnosis i asked
you
if the diagnostic and statistical manual
indicates
that famed amnesia is more commonly
found in individuals with legal problems
possibly so but that criteria that
amnesia does not appear in the dsm when
you look at malignant amnesia it's wrong
i could show you the data 80 percent of
the time
now i'm not saying
that anyway
and doctor i'm just asking you about
your diagnosis yes you diagnosed the
defendant with
the social media associated
dissociative amnesia localized
and you would agree with me that in the
comments or the follow-up statements
about dissociative amnesia it talks
about feigned amnesia in that same
paragraph they use the word malingering
and they use the word feign those are
two different concepts i don't know if
they made a mistake or what the authors
of
the american psychiatric association
made a mistake so they published the
csm5 so look on page 715 i believe at 7
15 for conditions v codes and on that
page
it discusses malingering
and those diagnoses malingering are
wrong 80 percent of the time
now you
indicated we just read rather
that it's true that individuals who
malinger
may confess spontaneously
okay
you would agree with me at least
that that's what we just read out of the
american
psychiatric association's dsm-5 okay yes
you would agree that michael barrasson
was overheard
at the scene saying i had a good life
okay
you would agree that he was overheard in
the ambulance saying is this real and i
need to wake up yes
you'd agree that in the ambulance he
also said
someone drove down my driveway and said
she was going to take my kids yes
you'd agree that the defendant was
overheard later at the hospital saying
they destroyed my life in the last six
months and they took it all away yes
did you ask him what he meant by any of
those statements yes
did he tell you that he doesn't know he
doesn't know what they meant he doesn't
even know
how his arm was broken
and you believe the the timing and
substance of those specific statements
is vague
they're not vague but you have to have a
context
didn't you write your report that they
were vague
well i i asked him what they meant i
didn't know what they meant
i don't know if
what he's referring to or those
statements are referring to
it's not clear to me do you recall in
the written statement that he wrote for
dr simran
where he indicated on a certain page
that after the
dcp worker got there and he was in his
office
that he only remembered two or three
things that were blurry at best
that's in his report
dr simran's report but i i didn't ask
that what he remembered
i asked him the last thing he remembered
the defendant saying he remembered two
or three things and it's blurry at best
is in dr simmering's report i believe i
believe it's in dr simran's report
but i or it's in um
the
51 the 91 pages but i didn't ask him on
that i asked him the last thing he
remembered so you didn't ask him what
the two to three things were that he
remembered after he was in his office
after what he said when he said he
remembered was
a lightning bolt coursing through his
body feeling confused had trouble
breathing it was like he was having a
panic attack and he didn't know where he
was what he was doing and the next thing
he remembered was waking up at the
hospital
and then i said well what was the first
thing you what you recall when you were
waking up and he said to me i asked for
a priest and then i asked if my children
were safe
i had asked you the question earlier
doctor
are you going through a different area
all right we'll break now it's about uh
20 of we want 10 minutes over i don't
want to go any further
you get the morning off ladies and
gentlemen
and we're going to resume at 1 30 or as
close to 1 30 as we can
so please be here about around one
o'clock or so 1 15 at the latest all
right thank you all please don't discuss
the case
you